okay everyone we just learned that The
Walking Dead's leading man Andrew
Lincoln who plays Rick Grimes will not
continue on the series throughout season
nine currently he has planned for a six
episode arc in season nine after which
he will depart from the series Lincoln
is the only cast member to remain on the
show from its pilot in 2010
Chandler Riggs Carl was killed off this
past season and Lenny James Morgan
returned for the past few seasons he was
gone for a bit now he recently moved on
to fear of The Walking Dead and really
after Andrew Lincoln the only cast
members left from season 1 are Norman
Reedus who plays Daryl and Melissa
McBride who plays Carol AMC is
reportedly in talks with Norman Reedus
to give him a race to 20 million dollars
to stay on the show throughout season 9
or you could cancel it or you could
cancel that's the that's kind of the
question now right because the death of
Carl was such a huge shocker to viewers
because Carl was really the future of
the storylines and Robert Kirkman's
comics he kind of becomes sort of what
seems like the the successor to lose
Rick would be an even bigger blow he
really is the heart of the series so I
mean he could say that maybe Daryl and
Carol and negan are certainly strong
supporting characters I would say having
watched all these episodes more than
once the way their characters have been
used in recent seasons has kind of lost
some of the enthusiasm at least I have
had for them and in past seasons like 3
& 4 but I don't know do you guys think
there is a future for the show how what
could a future look like if Daryl's now
the leading man on the show or is it
really time to call it quits
whenever shows have made these kind of
tougher calls to try to keep going when
the lead actor leaves it's never they
don't last long they'll probably get
another season usually Walking Dead is
the biggest show cables ever had period
forever and ever amen but like that you
can only keep going for so long and
since fan excitement for the show I
don't know specific numbers off the top
of my head of what kind of like
viewership they 7817 yeah it actually
was 17 million viewers for the negan
glance ode it's dropped it's now beneath
10 million viewers in episode 4 many be
upset the season 8 but I started really
good anyway yeah that I wouldn't see the
show going much further
again I am NOT the biggest fan of
Walking Dead so I do not know well let's
try to come up with a way that if the
show had to keep going because money
then I don't know that it's Norman
Reedus leading the same story again
right like right Andrew Lincoln did a
good job in his character you know even
in the comics like they almost run out
of stuff to where to take his character
he just becomes an old man basically
some talks that maybe lauren cohan as as
maggie could she could she's also her
contract has been kind of in question
whether she's gonna read these are
actors that want to have careers right
outside of just this one show which
especially you know angel incan was
starting to age out of it I'm sure he
also is sick of having a beard yeah but
what is the version of this show that
say they were like okay we're gonna do a
hard pivot you know is there another
thing my gut always goes to this I know
that this is story has been told I
always really like like military and
like like the White House version like
what would happen to the president what
happened to the vice president always
loved seeing the the institutions
crumble yeah they could be interesting
to follow an institutional Darabont
wanted to do from the the guy in the
tank from the I was the same way his
voice of Darth Maul in actual dark
moments alright yeah heat they were
gonna follow him in season two as we
know a little bit a little bit it's
tough right cuz fear The Walking Dead
already showed us a version of like the
earlier part of the timeline right and
when they didn't show us they showed us
kind of what I think I'm saying is like
pretty common to see is like the little
band of military that's always supposed
to be like salvation but then it ends up
being corrupt kind of thing but I think
like what about like a version of like
Apocalypse Now or something like a
Colonel Kurtz figure that's out there
and like actually has you know he has
sees himself as the head of the
government now because he's the highest
ranking military official and then like
you know but he's also corrupt and maybe
other military people have to take him
out or something like I don't know I
could see some sort of thing there but
again I'm talking about pretty hard
finish that would have to be a hard
pivot I think there's a version of this
I could maybe and this is probably what
they would try to do if Norman Reedus
Reedus ended up taking up the show it's
basically have Norman Reedus as the
leader of the survivors of the
Alexandria safe zone and how
the whisper storyline with him and he
has to deal with alpha and all the
characters who are connected with the
whisperers which doesn't sound that
exciting because really it's maybe it's
just a version of Darryl we know is from
recent seasons where he's really just
been like running around the woods
grunting when also storyline is not it's
not like there's one wave decode thing
that happens the show could benefit from
taking some creative you know choices of
making some creative choices of their
own and changing it up a little bit but
I mean if you have safe bet for me you
go with the fan favorite character and
that's Norman Reedus I know that you you
are right about ways to rile Darrell
right his current like situation the way
he's been portrayed but you could spend
some time like growing him making him
actually like develop more so I think
the show needs to be smaller like AMC if
you're looking for a way to save money
with this like season one just felt so
intimate and on a personal level like
the opening sequence which you know
pretty much adapted frame for frame from
Robert Kirkman's comics had like this is
28 days later feeling to it and it felt
like yeah this is a very interesting
story now it just feels like post
apocalyptic politics in a way that
sometimes is interesting but overall
just feels like we're jumping around to
be plots and episodes with characters
that we aren't that excited about but I
think there's a way can make this work
instead of maybe doing eight episodes
and a tip so it's 16 verses you got to
fill up like maybe just have like a six
episode arc and maybe make that all of
season nine and if it does well make it
six great episodes and then decide which
characters you want to bring back for
season 10 which could be just another
six episodes if you decide to go that
way yeah I think the biggest issue of
the show had is that and it had to
because of logic it's been on so long
they had to figure out how to deal with
walkers and they did
mm-hm and so the biggest threat the
titular threat of the show stopped
mattering right it was now the walkers
on the show are almost the idea of like
yeah Karl got in a car accident or
something right it's like this thing
that like if everything goes according
to plan you shouldn't even be worried
about the walkers and then oh no the dam
broke and he drowned in walkers like the
walkers have just become kind of
background set dressing yeah yeah like
like just like whoa this rock is
slippery uh like like that's what it
feels like to be attacked by Walker now
instead of that Lou
threat that almost like Michael Myers
represents that is like always right
behind you and you just don't know it so
my favorite moment of the show was when
they had no grounds like no nowhere to
be they were just camping mm-hmm and
it's like one of the most shocking
moments this season one is they they're
camping out Rick hasn't gotten back to
them or he just about to or something
and they're just in the middle of woods
and they're sitting around the campfire
and they just get over taking about
walkers
no the camera pans around there's a
walker grilling a s'more right feeling
like there's always one right there
talking bad about the walkers there's
one right behind me but that feeling
that the Walker was always right behind
you kind of thing right and then totally
gone so maybe if you put Daryl on the
road maybe you don't get that back yeah
going back to basics not a bad idea
yeah well guys let us know what you
think and and be kind because I know
there's a lot of like strong opinions
about what to do with the walking dead
but we have loved this show from the
beginning and like you we've had some
seasons some episodes that we love some
of that we don't but yeah as a fan is
there a version of the show it's easy
just to say like no let's we're done
with it and I think all of us feel that
way on some level too but we won't hear
your ideas for like what version of The
Walking Dead if it does continue what
version of it do you want to see let us
know in the comments below
reminder to subscribe to new rock stars
where all of our updates and deep dives
in all of shows movies you love thanks
guys